Benghazi
the way we investigated it and the level
of accountability that whoever was
involved at that time say Hillary
Clinton uh was Justice served uh based
on what happened to Benghazi and the
four folks that we lost out there
I'm not known for being subtle so let me
say yes for a basic reason you're
talking about a fairly isolated
diplomatic facilities in a hostile
country
and you want to anticipate in hundreds
of facilities overseas that you can
manage basically a mob trying to storm
that facility
if you want to make Fortress America
which if you travel overseas we already
see
you can do that these facilities are
supposed to be open to people they're
supposed to be open to Visa Seekers
but when I saw that I saw a tragedy I
saw a tragedy that should be
investigated that's why I say I agree
with an investigation that investigation
should be looking at the question of
whether there's culpability
but there's a tougher question that says
how do we balance having hundreds of
facilities so there is a there is a
both a cultural issue here about how
America wants to be perceived but
there's also a financial issue here do
you want to build fortresses in every
tiny consulate around the planet
how do you look at that and say we
should anticipate this kind of mob
coming into this kind of location and
have every place not only secured but
have a backup plan to ensure that we can
respond and evacuate I I just
we do 45 seconds on TV and that doesn't
do a service to this problem it goes
back to the question of saying if you
want to say that Benghazi was a Hillary
Clinton problem and that we should have
responded more quickly and prevented
loss of life
spend some time making the counter
argument about how difficult would
difficult it would be to plan in
sub-Saharan Africa and North Africa in
the middle east and south Asia and
Southeast Asia and East Asia for every
diplomatic location we have to plan to
make sure that never happens and I'm
going to say good luck you can't do it
perfect so if we hold that kind of
accountability to her then we have to
hold a similar kind of accountability of
lack of perfection doesn't exist
anywhere which is fine we have to stay
consistent yes Fair okay so if we're
going to say Hillary's not perfect we
have to keep going with that so 30 000
emails okay on what happened her break
in the laptops the phones all that stuff
was the was the right level of
accountability
held to Hillary Clinton for what she did
and every time they asked her questions
she's like yeah uh I don't know yeah I
don't know that's
you you mentioned but earlier I'm a
political commentator I'm not I comment
on it because people ask but I'll give
it a semi-political answer I think yes
if you look at at the information that
was in those emails it's not clear to me
that Revelation that revealing that
information was
hugely substantial for National Security
or could have led the loss of life so in
terms of legal responsibility I'd say I
don't know how much money the US wants
to spend on this case going back to what
I said earlier if you can anticipate a
defense attorney who's going to have a
good case too so we're going to spend a
ton of money and remember resources are
finite if I'm the attorney general I'm
saying man this is going to be a ton of
people how many I'd rather put those
people on child porn I'd rather put them
on gangs
the other thing though I'd say the flip
side of this is I think she paid a
tremendous price in in terms of
authenticity in turn this is where I
will make a vague political comment in
terms of people passing judgment
and to be blunt I think some of that was
appropriate when I saw some of the
answers about why this was on there what
I knew what I knew was classified and
didn't I'm like as a guy who did this
for for decades
that that dog don't hunt I thought there
was way too much bobbing and weaving way
too much avoiding questions and I
thought a lack of responsibility and and
looking at a camera and don't give me
yes but yes but I didn't give me a break
anybody who deals with National Security
information knows what's going on here
if you look at some of the information
in there it is classified
sorry it is now I don't think as I said
there should have been a criminal charge
or a civil charge but I do think the
American people judged her and based on
the answers I saw I'm not saying you
should solely judge her on that basis
but people who judged her and said this
is inauthentic okay I'm with that that's
fine so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]